[Música]
noticias de la salud con más Romero
salamar Buenos días para usted Buenos
días Ángela y muy buenos porque un
hombre paralizado pudo volver a
controlar sus movimientos con su mente
además Sí ahora explicaremos bien Qué
significa qué significa eso Es un avance
muy importante en la neurociencia en los
avances tecnológicos en este campo que
buscan devolver la movilidad a personas
que han perdido precisamente Pues el
control de sus cuerpos a raíz de
accidentes en este caso el paciente se
llama gardn Oscar tuvo un accidente de
bicicleta hace 10 años que lo dejó con
una lesión medular a la altura del
cuello aproximadamente Y eso hizo que
perdiera el control y el movimiento en a
sus extremidades inferiores y que
tuviera un movimiento limitado en los
brazos porque la lesión no fue completa
digamos que la médula espinal no quedó
cortada completamente ahora puede
gracias a estos avances caminar largas
distancias con muletas subir escaleras
caminar por superficies irregulares y a
pesar de que es un avance solo para una
persona difícilmente todavía traducible
a gran escala no deja de ser dor
escuchémosle
me dijeron No no te podemos ayudar
podría mover mis brazos y me dijeron que
me contentara con eso
Nunca creí que podría volver a andar Y
aunque no me basara en nada mantuve la
esperanza
cómo funciona esta tecnología más pues
tal y como lo han descrito los
científicos responsables del estudio y
de pues este iba a llamarlo experimento
no de este avance digamos lo mejor es
que es un puente digital entre el
cerebro y la médula espinal no hay dos
implantes en el cerebro del paciente que
lo que hacen es recoger los impulsos
cerebrales de esta persona de alguna
forma leerle los pensamientos no los
envían a una interfaz que está en la
mochila que lleva el paciente esta
interfaz lo que hace es decodificar
estos pensamientos traducirlos entonces
en estimulación eléctrica y estas
señales eléctricas van a unos sensores a
unos electrodos que también tiene
implantados el paciente en la médula
espinal especialmente en la zona lumbar
para ordenar el movimiento así el
paciente lo que puede es pensar en el
movimiento y eso se traduce en que logra
hacerlo no por primera vez en mucho
tiempo en lo que hace Entonces es
digamos sortear esa lesión medular que
vemos que tiene el paciente a la altura
del cuello más o menos y volver a estas
regiones del sistema nervioso es un
trabajo de una precisión increíble Así
explicado suena muy fácil pero requiere
unos avances tecnológicos una
comprensión de nuestro sistema nervioso
muy compleja de conseguir y además
también tiene la ayuda de Inteligencia
artificial en este caso de lo que
llamamos aprendizaje automático Machine
learning no que es lo que usa pues esta
interfaz para ir comprendiendo cada vez
mejor e ir aprendiendo sobre la marcha a
comprender las señales neuronales del
paciente escuchemos al Principal
investigador
tiene implantes a nivel cerebral de la
médula espinal en el abdomen para
estimular la médula sí es un poco un
Cyborg de alguna manera Nuestro objetivo
es mejorar su vida cotidiana su calidad
de vida y debemos calibrar estos logros
no puede andar como tú o como yo pero
por primera vez en la historia de la
humanidad hemos conseguido reconectar
dos regiones del sistema nervioso que
estaban separadas por una lesión madura
ojo que lo que usted me está diciendo es
que Inteligencia artificial se traduce
en pensamientos en movimiento se traduce
en pensamientos en estímulos eléctricos
que consiguen hacer movimientos y Dios
mío este último avance es el resultado
de años y años de investigación no se
esperaría Pues nada menos no Claro por
supuesto pero quería destacarlo porque a
veces parece que estos avances salgan de
la nada y no esto es el resultado de al
menos una década de investigación del
equipo de que estábamos escuchando
justamente ahora con muchos otros
científicos como Jocelyn por ejemplo que
lo hacen en losana en Suiza el primer
experimento que hicieron en la primera
Avance en este sentido significativo fue
en 2014 cuando lograron que hacer
caminar y moverse a unas ratas con
lesiones medulares que por lo tanto
habían quedado sin movimiento no en sus
extremidades luego dos años después lo
lograron Reproducir con monos importante
aquí decir que estos animales no
controlaban su movimiento sino que
estaba controlado por programas de
ordenador externos manejados por los
científicos en 2018 se consiguió en
humanos tres pacientes lograron volver a
caminar y es interesante porque uno de
ellos Precisamente es Oscar en este
mismo este mismo hombre que ahora ha
dado Este paso más allá y lo que hacían
era Pues con rehabilitación y
estimulación medular lograron volver no
a caminar con muletas y en 2022 lo
logran con tres pacientes más Pero ellos
Sí tenían una lesión total medular
Entonces estos han sido los avances que
preceden este último paso en este
sentido todo este como vemos todo avance
Es un logro No de hecho han conseguido
que Oscar pueda seguir andando y
mejorando sus conexiones es como si
gracias a llevar estos implantes sus
neuronas y sus temas nervioso hubiera
reaprendido algunas cosas que había
olvidado sin embargo Pues por supuesto
queda mucho por delante Tuvo que pasar
por muchas cirugías para conseguir poder
volver a caminar con todos estos
implantes Eso hace que ahora mismo sea
difícil pensarlo como decíamos a gran
escala pero sin duda nos habla mucho de
todo lo que se puede lograr con
investigación y también con recursos por
supuesto pues mi remar me deja sin
palabras absolutamente Muchas gracias
por esta información que nos trae hoy
tan valiosa Muchas gracias Ángela